salue jack je peux avoir une grande
bouteille de bail joues tu sais quoi
balance moi deux grandes bouteilles
comment tu arrives à boire autant je me
plaignais d'avoir à subir chaque jour la
même chose maintenant tous les jours
c'est pareil
je suis mort 144 fois tu es chaque jour
se termine comme ça mais ça n'a pas
d'importance pas quand vous avez perdu
tout ce que vous aimiez
20 heures l'homme qui m'a déjà tué 150
fois le pouvoir de réécrire l'histoire
et le mur fais gaffe je sais tout ce qui
va m'arriver
[Musique]
j'ai pour toi roj tu m'entends bien
la seule femme que j'ai jamais mais qui
peut arrêter ça est encore en vie
je dois me faire tuer encore et encore
jusqu'à ce que je la sauva
je dois apprendre à me battre à l'épée
je n'ai qu'un jour vous consacrez je
crois qu'on peut faire beaucoup on à
jour
[Musique]
dans une spirale mortelle à cause de toi
c'est que nous art
qu'ils amènent tous jusqu'au dernier
[Applaudissements]
je peux faire ça toute la journée
[Musique]